le département vous présente terre de
trail
[Musique]
bonjour après plus de cinquante
kilomètres de course le plateau de la
plaine et qu'a fait la jonction entre
les deux volcans qui ont façonné lille
c'est là que je décide de changer de
chemin car sous nos pieds existe un
univers connu de lorenzo sert sauveur
bonjour le 22 500 heures donc fait
technicien la direction environnement du
département où je m'occupe des espaces
naturels sensibles
on est où là là on est à la peine et que
donc on est sur le site d'écouté
c'est une propriété montclos d'idées par
contre face à faire est sensible
l'endroit secret alors on est sur le
spot de la biodiversité la terre et
patrie mère du site c'est ce qui est en
dessous et attention moi je passe sur
les fleurs un panneau bon protéger cette
zone mais c'est pas pour les âmes en
europe quand même si on a mis ça donc
c'est pour protéger donc qui fait le
caractère patrimonial du site
mais c'est une grotte
exactement c'est une grotte donc il ya
un réseau de tunnels deux kilomètres qui
court sur toute la pologne
[Musique]
placés pour voir les éléments la
banquette et le côté fluide de cette
lave cordée qui a laissé pencher
peut-être vers le tampon se vivre est un
endroit comme ça pour un spéléologue
justement ah ben oui c'est un ministère
plein d'inconnues les anciens te disais
la flamme et la flamme y est un donc on
savait pas trop où aller jusqu'au bout
et donc on arrive à maintenant découvrir
des jouets à joyeux qui est quasiment
unique sur terre un monde souterrain peu
connu car pour le moment fermé au public
c'est l'ange de ce territoire je pense
que la majorité des coureurs n'imagine
pas donc qui sont à côté d'un site
exceptionnel et que sous leurs pieds
beaucoup à quelques mètres donc donc ils
ont donc des tunnels de lave qui
parcourt le site et avec une richesse
aussi aussi importante l'idée c'est de
pouvoir ouvrir ce site mais de façon
encadrée et pouvoir mettre en place des
actions de lutte pour des espèces
invasives
donc voilà c'est pas des actions on ne
vendait pas là pour faire connaître le
site on va là pour dans un premier
enfant dans un premier temps deux pour
le protéger et puis donc si on peut
l'ouvrir au public par la suite donc ça
c'est un petit peu la cerise sur le
gâteau halle aux toiles un petit moment
ils écoutent un petit peu donc on entend
les saints l'organe donc et puis je
pense que la nature parle d'elle-même
donc si on se pose on s'arrête un petit
moment pour qu'on se laisse envahir par
l'ambiance tout autour de nous donc
et puis voilà on se laisse on sait sans
remporté par la nature ça c'est beau ah
ça c'est bissonnet va faire bien le
département vous a présenté terre de
travail